AND RAMPANT INFLATION,
PETE BUTTIGIEG TRYING TO SPIN
THE DISASTER AS A RESULT OF
JOE BIDEN SUCCESS.
>> CERTAINLY A LOT OF CHALLENGES
WE HAVE BEEN EXPERIENCING THIS
YEAR WILL CONTINUE INTO NEXT
YEAR, BUT THERE ARE BOTH
SHORT-TERM AND LONG-TERM STEPS
THAT WE CAN TAKE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
PART OF WHAT IS HAPPENING IS NOT
JUST THE SUPPLY SIDE, IT'S THE
DEMAND SIDE.
DEMAND IS UP BECAUSE INCOME IS
UP BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT HAS
SUCCESSFULLY GUIDED THIS ECONOMY
OUT OF THE TEETH OF A TERRIFYING
RECESSION.
>> Jesse: MEANWHILE AMERICANS
GETTING CRUSHED BY INFLATION AS
WE HEAD CLOSER TO THE HOLIDAYS.
ONE IN FIVE AMERICANS ALREADY
STARTED THEIR HOLIDAY SHOPPING
LAST MONTH.
ALL RIGHT, DANA, WE HAVE EMPTY
SHELVES, HIGH INFLATION, SOARING
GAS PRICES, LABOR SHORTAGES AND
A MIGRATION CRISIS AND IN THIS
COUNTRY AND PROBABLY ANY OTHER,
IF YOU HAD SAID MAYBE THREE OF
THOSE THINGS, THAT'S A POLITICAL
CRISIS, BIDEN HAS ALL OF THEM.
>> Dana: YOU COME PLACE THEM
BACK WITH POLICY DECISIONS THAT
HAVE CONSEQUENCES, SO YOU HAVE
ALL OF THOSE THINGS HAPPENING
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU OVER
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY COMING
IT'S ALL JUST LAST WEEK OVER 50%
OF PEOPLE POLLED BY GALLUP SAID
WE DON'T WANT GOVERNMENT TO GET
ANY BIGGER, WE DON'T THINK WE
NEED ANY OF THIS EXTRA MONEY.
THEY REALIZE THAT WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
YOU HAVE INCREASED DEMAND, NOT
ENOUGH SUPPLY, WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN?
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT
MAYOR PETE HAS BEEN QUITE
INDIGNANT, HE IS FRUSTRATED THAT
PEOPLE SAY THAT MAYBE HE SHOULD
OF BEEN ON PATERNITY LEAVE, TAKE
YOUR PATERNITY LEAVE, BUT IF YOU
TAKE LEAVE, THAT MEANS THAT
SOMEDAY PHIL'S IMPROVED JOB, AND
I LOOKED IT UP AND THERE IS A
DEPUTY TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY,
HER NAME IS POLLY TOTENBERG, AND
I DON'T REMEMBER SEEING HER OUT
THERE EITHER.
ALL OF THESE ISSUES COME IN LATE
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRYING TO FAST
THINGS LIKE THE HUMAN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AND THEY
FORGET THAT ALL OF THESE THINGS
ARE HAPPENING.
>> Jesse: WHEN I TOOK MY
PATERNITY LEAVE I WAS ONLY GONE
FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS AND SOMEONE
TOOK MY PLACE HERE AT THE TABLE.
WHAT DID THEY CALL IT "THE FOUR"
THE ENTIRE PATERNITY?
>> Greg: THIS IS A GREAT TEST
FOR GOVERNMENT, IF NOBODY
NOTICES THE LOSS OF SERVICES OR
THAT YOU ARE NOT THERE, MAYBE
GET RID OF HIM?
MAYBE YOU SHOULD BE FIRED.
THE FACT THAT NO ONE IN THE
MEDIA DID A WELFARE CHECK, WE
HAVE NOT SEEN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY, ARE YOU OKAY?
ARE YOU OKAY?
I'M GOING TO START USING THE
EXCUSE OF BOTTLE-FEEDING.
BECAUSE TECHNICALLY I AM FEEDING
MYSELF, BUT AS A PERSON, PETE IS
RIGHT TO TAKE OFF THAT TIME IF
IT IS AVAILABLE.
BUT AS A LEADER, HE IS AN
EMBARRASSMENT.
NO LEADER IN THE TIME OF CRISIS
WOULD TAKE TWO MONTHS OFF, EVEN
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES DON'T DO
THAT, THEY TAKE OFF A FEW GAMES
HERE AND THERE.
BUT YOU HAVE TO COME TO WORK
WHEN THERE'S SOMETHING GOING ON,
BUT THE CHAOS WITH THIS WHOLE
CARGO THING, HIS EXPERIENCE IS
THE PERFECT METAPHOR.
IT DID NOT DISTURB HIS
LIFESTYLE.
HE IS AN ELITE WHO IS ABLE TO
TAKE THE EIGHT WEEKS OFF,
BECAUSE IT DID NOT HAMMER HIM.
IT HAMMERS THE MIDDLE CLASS AND
IT'S GOING TO HAMMER THE WORKING
CLASS, BUT SOMEDAY LIKE HIM WELL
EDUCATED, GRABBED A GREAT JOB IN
GOVERNMENT, HE CAN WEATHER IT.
THERE'S JUST SOMETHING WEIRD
ABOUT A MAYOR OF A CITY COME OF
A CITY THAT WASN'T SO MUCH
TROUBLE LIKE CLEVELAND THAT HE
DECIDED INSTEAD OF STICKING TO
THE JOB AND FIXING THINGS, HE
RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
IF SO THAT MAKES YOU SMART, BUT
IT MAKES YOU A TERRIBLE LEADER.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE FINDING OUT
IS THAT HE ABANDONED THE CITY,
THE CITY OF TWINKLY LIGHTS
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN.
>> Jesse: RICHARD, HE SAYS OUR
SUPPLY CHAIN CAN'T KEEP UP,
WHERE DID HE AND ALL OF HIS
McKINSEY GUYS PUT THE SUPPLY
CHAIN?
IN CHINA!
THEY CAN'T KEEP UP BECAUSE THEY
ARE HALFWAY AROUND THE WORLD!
>> Richard: HE DID NOT PUT IT
IN CHINA.
>> Jesse: McKENZIE SAID TO
PUT THEM IN CHINA, YOU AVOID
REGULATIONS AND TAXES AND YOU
HAVE TO PAY THEM LESS.
A SPEAKER THERE IS NOTHING MORE
THAN I WANT FOR ALL OF OUR
SUPPLY CHAINS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE REALITY AND I WILL ALSO
GRANT YOU THAT I THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WAS SLOW TO THE
MIC AND ADDRESSING HOW WE DEAL
WITH THE SUPPLY-CHAIN ISSUE.
IT'S WORTH POINTING OUT THAT THE
SUPPLY-CHAIN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
ARE FAR BIGGER THAN JOE BIDEN
AND THEY ARE FAR BIGGER THAN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WE HAVE A GLOW --
>> Jesse: SHOW BIDEN HAS BEEN
IN CONTROL FOR FOUR DECADES.
IT >> Richard: I DID NOT
INTERRUPT YOU, WE ARE DEALING
WITH THE GLOBAL NEWS AND DEALING
WITH LAST WEEK IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM THEY RAN OUT OF
FUEL BECAUSE THEY HAD THE
SUPPLY-CHAIN ISSUE HAPPENING
THERE AND THE SUPPLY-CHAIN ISSUE
HAVE BEEN BECAUSE IT STARTED IN
20001 CHINESE FACTORY SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE OF COVID-19, AND WE HAD
BOARDERS IN CHINA THAT WERE TWO
MONTHS BEHIND AND THEN WHEN
CHINA AND THEIR PRODUCTS TO THE
UNITED STATES, OUR PORTS SHUT
DOWN BECAUSE WE HAD COVID-19 AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING ISSUES, SO NOW
WE ARE DEALING WITH THE RELAY
RACE THAT IS ABOUT 100 YARDS
BACK WHEN WE ARE TRYING TO CATCH
UP, SO YES, YOU ARE RIGHT,
THOUGH BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS
SLOW TO THE PATH TO SAY HERE'S
WHAT WE ARE DEALING WITH AND
HERE'S WHY IT IS HAPPENING.
TO LIKE YOU SAID AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEGMENT WE HAVE
A LABOR SHORTAGE THAT IS
HAPPENING WITH TRUCKERS AND
LONGSHOREMEN, WHICH IS ALSO
IMPACTING THE DOWNWARD PRESSURE
ON WHAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW, SO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE SEEING EMPTY SHELVES
AND WAITING THREE AND FOUR
MONTHS TO GET THEIR SOAP, THEIR
MANY COOPERS, THEIR iPHONE 13,
BUT THE RESULT OF IT IS A
GLOBALIZED PROBLEM THAT IS A
RESULT OF THE FACT THAT WE JUST
DEALT WITH A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THAT AFFECTED THE WHOLE WORLD
AND WHERE WE SHUT THE LIGHT
SWITCH OFF OF THE ENTIRE GLOBAL
ECONOMY.
>> Katie: WHY WAS THAT,
BECAUSE OF GOVERNMENT POLICY?
>> Richard: BECAUSE MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS DIED.
>> Katie: AND IN THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT POLICY TO STOP
PRODUCTION TO STOP PRODUCTION TO
IMPLEMENT RESTRICTIONS THAT DID
NOT ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET BACK TO
WORK AND HELD OFF THOSE
RESTRICTIONS WERE FAR TOO LONG
BECAUSE OF SOME POLITICAL
MOTIVES LIKE WITH GAVIN NEWSOM
IN CALIFORNIA, BACK TO
PETE BUTTIGIEG, WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, PEOPLE IN
THE PRIMARY AND DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY WERE SAYING, HE CAN'T
EVEN FIX POTHOLES IN SOUTH BEND,
WHERE WE GOING TO NOT ONLY ELECT
HIM AS PRESIDENT, BUT HE'S GOING
TO BE JOE BIDEN'S TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY, PETE BUTTIGIEG WAS ON
PATERNITY LEAVE, SAYS HE DID NOT
HAVE TIME TO APPOINT SOMEONE TO
TAKE OVER HIS JOB, OFF THE CLOCK
AND HAVE PLENTY OF TIME TO
PARTICIPATE IN A DOCUMENTARY AND
PLENTY OF TIME TO DO AN
INTERVIEW WITH "PEOPLE" MAGAZINE
ABOUT HIS NEW LIFE, SO IT'S JUST
A MATTER OF PRIORITIZING HIS
FAME AND WANTING TO PULL A FAUCI
BEING ON THE COVER OF MAGAZINES
VERSUS DEALING WITH REAL
PROBLEMS THAT AMERICA IS HAVING
RIGHT NOW WITH THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
THE FINAL THING I WILL SAY IS
NOW THAT THE FORCES ARE BACK UP
IN CALIFORNIA, THEY NEED PEOPLE
TO OFF-LOAD WHAT IS IN THE PORT
AND THEY NEED DRIVERS, THAT'S
THE SHORTAGE OF WORKERS.
CALIFORNIA LABOR LAW THROUGH 85
DOES NOT ALLOW THAT, WE CAN'T
HIRE GATE WORKERS.
THE PRO ACT WHICH IS IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THAT
JOE BIDEN WANTS TO PASS DOES THE
SAME THING ON A NATIONAL LEVEL.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON YOU HIRE HAS
TO BE A FULL-TIME EMPLOYEE WITH
FULL BENEFITS AND THEY DO THAT
BECAUSE THEY WANT THE UNIONS FOR
POLITICAL CAPITAL.
SO THIS PROBLEM IS NOT GETTING
FIXED ON A POLICY LEVEL ANYTIME
SOON WHETHER IT'S THROUGH THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OR THROUGH
CALIFORNIA POLITICS EITHER.
>> Jesse: I HEAR YOU SAYING
THAT IT'S THE DEMOCRATS FAULT?
>> Katie: YES, VERY MUCH SO.
>> Jesse: AND RICHARD, THE
REASON THEY ARE HAVING FUELS TO
SHORTAGES IN EUROPE I